matin on verra tout ça et on va
continuer à parler de ce sujet avec
l'ancien ministre de l'Agriculture
Stéphane Lefol nous
rejoint et ben dites donc et notre
invité politique ce matin c'est Stéphane
lefolle bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ma socialiste duent
ancien ministre de l'agriculture on a on
va évidemment beaucoup parler de ce
sujet on est ensemble pant en 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse régionale représenté par
Fabrice vesser Redon du groupe et brra
bonjour Fabrice bonjour Orian bonjour
Stéphane Lefol bonjour Stéphane lefolle
la FNSEA et les jeunes agriculteurs
d'Île-de-France appellent donc à un
siège de Paris pour une durée
indéterminée est-ce que vous les
encourager à ce blocage
non je trouve que la FSEA qui au début a
été débordé par ce qui s'est passé dans
le Sud-Ouest en Occitanie et j'aurai un
mot d'ailleurs pour Monsieur B he c'est
sa baille qui a été
Jérôme B qui a été après avoir obtenu ce
qu'il souhaitait en partie a été
beaucoup insulté bon aujourd'hui il y a
une espèce de de volonté de récupérer ce
qui s'est passé et puis de bloquer Paris
avec les J et la fn donc on est vraiment
sur le syndicalisme majoritaire qui
s'engage maintenant sur ce blocage non
je va pas les encourager moi j'ai pas
connu ça à l'époque j'ai connu beaucoup
de crises qui étaient des crises de
marché et jeis doné comme exemple quand
même pour que chaque bien en tête ce que
ça représente he on était sur la tonne
de lait à l'époque en pleine crise
laitière à 240 € la tonne aujourd'hui on
est à plus de
440 ça va baisser et c'est ça qui a été
le vrai sujet c'est que après une montée
des prix on a une baisse et à ce
moment-là était arrivé la détaxation la
fin de la détaxation du GNR et je
comprends qu'avec la montée des charges
les agriculteurs se sont se soit dit ça
y est on va refaire l'effet ciseau mais
aujourd'hui il faut se mettre autour
d'une table il y a des choses à discuter
il y a eu des propositions qui ont été
faites mais je l'ai dit dans plusieurs
interviews et j'aurais l'occasion de
réécrire un texte un peu plus sur le les
grands enjeux on a un gouvernement quand
même qui a qui sur l'agriculture a
flotter mais on va on va revenir sur les
enjeux MS le en même temps sur
l'agriculture ça a donné d'un côté je
supprime le glyphosate de l'autre je
finis par y renoncé ça a donné la loi
égalime uniquement la question des prix
ou de la répercussion de l'augmentation
des coûts rien sur le reste on va
revenir sur tout ça mais sur les
blocages vous vous dites c'est pas la
bonne méthode Gérald non mais je vais
pas encourager non et j'ai été ministre
j'ai été responsable pendant 5 ans je
vais pas me mettre à encourager des
blocages je comprends qu'il y a des
difficultés c'est une crise d'ailleurs
qui est extrêmement profonde parce que
elle elle elle mélange maintenant
beaucoup de sujet mais je vaux pas
encourager les blocages non ça peut ça
peut retour surtout je le dis hein tout
ça c'est parti de l'occitalie du
Sud-Ouest et
aujourd'hui la fédération nationale du
syndicalistme des exploitants agricoles
reprend ça en Blant par il y a pas que
le Sud-Ouest il y a quand même pas mal
de mois onvoit des panneaux de communes
à il y a quand même quelque chose qui
montait depuis plusieurs semaines
absolument il y mais c'est ce que je dis
il y a une crise qui est à la fois qui
pas simplement une crise de marché il y
a eu l'anticipation de l'inflexion ça
c'est certain qui n'est pas simplement
du Sud-Ouest oui mais tenez compte quand
même des situations très particulières
du sud-ouest avec ce qui a été et ce qui
est toujours le risque sur l'eau par
exemple qui s'ajoute le fait que les
agriculteurs qui vivent des des
sécheresses successives et ça va euh
être extrêmement difficile puisque les
naps sont pas rechargé je prends la
partie
ocitane proprement dit on est sur des
sujet aussi majeur mais il y a un
malaise et ça c'est incontestable je
l'ai dit c'est une crise morale
politique mais ça ne se traitera pas
simplement en bloquant Paris et la
région parisienne et en disant et en
disant quoi qu'est-ce qu'on peut changer
le le ministre et le Premier ministre
ont fait des propositions bon est que je
leur reproche c'est que depuis des
années il s'est rien passé c'est ça le
sujet mais est-ce que est-ce que Gérald
harmanin a eu raison de ne pas envoyer
les forces de l'ordre y compris quand il
y a eu des dégradations de bâtiments
public ça a été le cas à jein nim un
Carcasson il a eu raison pas intervenir
mais dans dans ce débat il faut éviter
bien sûr la surenchère mais il faut
aussi quand même avoir un minimum de
respect pour ce que sont les bâtiments
publics vous l'avez dit donc il a eu
raison d'éviter j'allais dire une
surenchère qui aurait pu être
extrêmement violente mais on n jamais
raison d'accepter la violence et la
dégradation parce que une fois qu'on
l'accepte pour certains faut pas
s'étonner qu'ensuite il y en a d'autres
qui se mettent à suivre donc il faut
quand même avoir j'ai trouvé les
premières déclarations de Gérald armanin
un peu quand
même manquant de de règles et de rappel
quand même à la r de fermeté et
justement il lui a été reproché d'emblé
un de poids de mesures dans le
traitement de ces ces manif c'est
l'impression que ça donné c'est c'est
les premièr phases qu'il a eu on fera
rien on laissera faire voilà alors que
dans d'autres cas ça a été beaucoup plus
difficile la détresse de certains
salariés elle est aussi grande que celle
que peuvent connaître les les
agriculteurs aujourd'hui pour pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux donc faisons
attention à avoir des discours
effectivement d'apaisement l'État n'est
pas là pour provoquer ni en rajouter
mais en même temps rappeler quand même
un minimum de règles alors il semblerait
que là il y a trois règles pas d'aoport
pas de paringi c'est pas le blocage de
Paris et pas de tracteur en Paris bon
très bien on et dans les grandes villes
vous vous avez beaucoup discuté vous
avec les FNSA quand vous étiez ministre
de l'Agriculture c'est le syndicat
majoritaire qui appelle donc aujourd'hui
au blocage alors qu' qu'elle a discuté
avec le gouvernement y compris sur les
modalités
de
taxation taxation vous avvez discuté
donc est-ce que vous comprenez
aujourd'hui son attitude est-ce qu' une
forme deirresonsabilité de la part je
trouve que là dans le dans la volonté de
rattraper de remîtriser un mouvement je
trouve qu'il y a une fuite en avant et
que une fois qu'on fait sortir des
agriculteurs et que une partie et vous
l'avez vu aussi sur le tgaron la partie
Coordination Rurale la plus dure va
vouloir
elle qui monter monter à ringis on
s'engage sur un sujet sur le qu la
responsabilité de chacun sera engagée
d'autant et vous l'avez très bien
rappelé qu'avant il y avait eu des
négociations bon donc et comment on sort
quelles sont les revendications où
va-t-on parce que la liste des je sais
plus 41 ou 50 mesures bon alors je sais
pas ce qu'il y a dans toutes ces mesures
il y a une partie qui ont dû être
entendu mais il sont pas les mêmes selon
les syndicats ouis ils sont pas les
mêmes selon les syndicat donc là il y a
quand même quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre de la responsabilité sera engagé
donc il y a une forme d'irresponsabilité
de la part de j'ai pas dit 10
responsabilité mais en tout cas il faut
rappeler chacun à la responsabilité
est-ce que comme Fabien Roussel l'a fait
cette semaine vous appelez à la
convergence des colère pour faire
pression sur le nouveau gouvernement je
regardais des documentaires sur le front
populaire sur cette convergence des
Lutes déjà à l'époque hein mais dans des
périodes où le communisme et le et le
socialisme cherchit justement ces
convergence j'entends d'ailleurs la
leader de la CGT de faire appel au
converg mais c'est je je me dis mais
comment ils en sont encore restés à
cette idée très marxisante de la
convergence des luttes et hier il y
avait un très bon reportage aussi sur
sur l'histoire de Lénine bon on n plus
du tout dans le même monde et
puis la FNSA d'ailleurs au m en 2006 a
fait le choix de dire et c'était une
erreur pour moi de dire et je l'ai dit
de dire que le chef d'exploitation est
devenu un chef d'entreprise donc on a à
faaire des chefs d'entreprise un des
côtés et de l'autre de salariés mais
cette idée de la convergence des luttes
ouvriers paysan qui date de la
révolution russe enfin je veux dire j'ai
envie de leur dire mais est-ce que vous
AZ bien regardé le problème aujourd'hui
c'est très j'ai écr un texte là-dessus
on n plus dans la lutte des classes on
est dans la lutte contre le déclassement
chacun dans sa propre vie individuelle
vit les difficultés comme un risque de
déclassement les agriculteurs comme
beaucoup de salariés donc tant qu'on a
pas compris et qu'on pas clé de lecture
ben on en est encore à la convergence
des luttes mais c'est quoi aujourd'hui
la clé de la revendication vous restez
un homme de gauche on est d'accord oui
comment on revendique aujourd'hui
comment on revendique ben la
manifestation je est-ce que je vous ai
indiqué autre chose que tout le monde
peut revendiquer et est-ce que la gauche
c'est uniquement la manifestation est-ce
que la gauche c'est uniquement la rue je
crois pas la gauche c'est aussi des
réformes c'est aussi porter le progrès
c'est aussi organiser la négociation et
le compromis je pas revenir sur les
vieilles idées de la social-démocratie
mais enfin à force de l'oublier et à
force d'avoir été soumis à cette ligne
de la convergence des luttes on finit
par oublier ce qu au fond une manière
démocratique de gérer et des colères et
des intérêts divergents ça commence par
organiser du dialogue et du dialogue
avec aussi des grands objectifs
politiques moi quand j'ai porté
l'agroécologie le 4 pour 1000
j'entendais pareil hier soir sur la 5 g
Gaspard Ken revendiquer le 4 pour j'ai
lancé ces opérations là j'ai pas
toujours été compris j'ai été sifflé
dans les congrès de la FNS
et de manière extrêmement virulente à
l'époque j'ai j'ai été considéré comme
ayant des difficultés comme ministre
mais parce que j'avais un cap changer
réformer se réorganiser aller vers
l'agroécologie avec une idée de
l'agriculture demain c'est pas toujours
facile mais ça doit se faire et
aujourd'hui il y a pas il y a pas cette
discussion et là dans les premières
mesures qu'a annoncé vendredi gabrielal
est-ce que pour vous ça va dans le bon
sens mais alors c'est un changement
complet c'est comme quand le président
de la République dit on interdit
glyphosate puis après on laisse l'Europe
le le remettre sans se mouiller en je
veux dire la même manière sur les
néonicï qui avait dit à l'époque qu'il
fallait qui avait dit à l'époque qu'il
fallait pas faire ça Stéphane Lefol de
gauche écolo quand je porte la gros mais
je sais qu'il y a des choses qu'on ne
fait pas et on fait pas faire des
zigzags à l'agriculture on essaie
d'avoir un cap faut baisser
l'utilisation des phytosanitaires
j'avais fait adopter les certificats
d'économie phytosanitaire qui ont été
supprimés dans le cadre de cette fameuse
loi égalime et c'est une erreur parce
qu'on aurait dû travailler depuis
longtemps sur la manière dont on réduit
mais en même temps qu'on réduit les
phytosanitaires et la chimie on cherche
des alternatives aujourd'hui à chaque
fois qu'on supprime une molécule on dit
mais il y a pas d'autres moléculle en
face ben non ça c'est c'est sûr c'est
pas une aujourd'hui parce que c'est ce
que disent les agriculteurs il y a pas
de solution on interdit il y a pas de
solution mais pourquoi parce que
personne n'a jamais cherché de solution
moi je sais très bien que l'objectif
qu'on avait fixé de baisse de 30 % des
phytosanitaires on pouvait tout à fait
l'atteindre tout à fait l'atteindre si
c'était C est-ce que dans l'état actuel
de l'agriculture il faut les interdire
ces pesticides ou on n' pas les moyens
pour le moment les CPP quel était
l'objectif c'était de dire que on
baissait les ventes de phyo en chimie de
30 % en 5 ans et que si au bout de 5 ans
il y avait pas eu la baisse de 30 % on
avait une taxe qui s'appliquait pour
pouvoir engager des processus on savait
très bien qu'on pouvait sur la base de
ce qu'avait été les fermes défi et les
expérimentations qui étaient fait
baisser de 30 % la totalité de
l'utilisation des phytosanitaires je
vais vous prendre des exemples très
simples quand vous regardez aujourd'hui
la vigne avec l'enherbement des vignes
il y a 20 ans une vigne elle devait être
propre sans herbe aujourd'hui on a
compris que c'était pas la peine
d'utiliser des herbicides on peut
combiner vigne et enherbement bon et on
économise d'autant plus d'herbicide en
particulier le fameux glyphosate donc
tout ça ça se travaille tout ça ça se
discute mais faut-il être capable encore
d'avoir une méthode et d'avoir des
objectifs il y a pas de méthode il y a
pas d'objectif donc au bout du compte
ben vous arriz et je vous entends et
très bien vous dites ben on interdit
mais il y a pas d'alternative bah oui et
on va continuer comme ça longtemps tant
qu'on se met pas en situation de
chercher des alternatives et de
s'organiser pour baisser le recours au
phyau et bien vous restez dans la
situation dans laquelle vous êtes donc
l'acroécologie c'est encore la voix à
suivre pour vous aujourd'hui c'est non
seulement la voie suivre est-ce qu'on
est-ce qu'il y a pas trop de normes
environnmentementales et de normes
écologiqu au détriment de agricul
justement l'agroécologie c'est pas les
normes c'est comment on s'organise pour
utiliser ce qui est disponible
c'est-à-dire la photosynthèse l'énergie
solaire les ce qui est gratuit je
reviens sur les les vers de terre qui
travaillent à à la place du Labour
comment on utilise tout ça pour éviter
d'être en sûr en besoin de financement
très important pour acheter du matériel
et comment on fait à partir de là pour
s'organiser pour y arriver c'est ça la
question j'avais mis en place les
groupements d'intérêts économiques et
environnementaux qui permettent de
regrouper de faire des assolements sur
beaucoup plus de surface ce qui est
beaucoup plus intelligent en terme de
rotation et ce qui permet justement
aussi d'éviter des recours en
multipliant la diversité des végétaux
que vous utilisez d'éviter d'utiliser
des sanitaire tout ça ça existe faut
avoir envie un mot un mot sur la
question des revenus après jene la
parole à Fabrice c'est aussi évidemment
l'un des sujets les faibles revenus de
beaucoup d'agriculteurs Gabriel hatal et
Bruno Lemer se sont montrés très fermes
ces derniers jours avec la grande
distribution pour qu'il respecte la loi
égalime qui est censé rééquilibrer les
choses entre les agriculteurs et la
grande distribution ils ont la bonne
ligne pour vous alors la loi égalime
c'est je répercute l'augmentation des
coûts de production sur les prix de
vente et la grande distribution doit les
répercuter c'est ça lagalim
si on dit que la grande distribution
fait trop de marge alors c'est pas la
loi é galime qu'il faut faire hein c'est
une loi qui limite les
marges vous voyez le le le problème donc
c'est pas c'est pas la PR fois la loigal
la lo égalim a moi je suis pas opposé à
loi égalim mais d'avoir tout focalisé
sur le légalim comme si d'ailleurs les
questions de marché les équilies sur le
marché n'existaient plus et qui avait
plus qu'une seule question c'était la
répercussion des coupts ça c'est la
c'était aussi une ligne de la f ça que
j'ai connu moi à l'époque j'étais sur la
contractualisation et j'étais pas
simplement sur C ce mécanisme il peut
être utile j'en discute pas mais
aujourd'hui si la question c'est la
grande distribution continue à faire des
marges en répercutant les coûts donc
elle les répercute plus ou moins bien si
elle continue à faire des marges ça veut
dire que elle vend un peu plus cher donc
c'est pas la question de la répercussion
des coûts qui est posé c'est la question
de la limitation des marges donc si
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire et Monsieur
hatal sont cohérents si c'est un
problème de marge faut limiter les
marges donc faire une autre loi hein
donc faire une autre loi refaire une loi
s'ils veulent faire ça si c'est ça leur
objectif c'est ça qu'il faut faire hier
dans le Journal du Dimanche ERC soti a
plaidé pour un revenu minimum net de
1500 € net par mois pour les
agriculteurs financés en sanctionnant
justement fortement les distributeurs
qui ne respectent pas égalim c'est une
bonne mesure pour vous je sais pas si
Éric STI a relu justement l'histoire du
monde agricole s'il a relu le congrès du
M de 2006 je l'ai dit on est passé de
chef d'exploitation à chef d'entreprise
on a individualisé le rapport j'allais
dire de manière économique on a ramené
l'exploitation à une entreprise bon bah
une entreprise si vous dites à des
entreprises aujourd'hui que vous allez
avoir un revenu minimum ça veut dire que
vous devz salariés donc je ne sais pas
où là on est dans la surenchère de de
propositions que qui vont arriver les
unes derrière les autres pour essayer de
régler tous les problèmes enfin Monsieur
soioti fait quelque fois des siotismes
c'estàd
je dire de dire on va faire un revenu
minimum sur l'agriculture à 1500 € ça
veut dire qu'on est sur un sic mais à ce
moment-là on est dans le salariat on est
plus dans l'exploitation agricole oui
vousmême vous vous préconisez vous
prenez la refonte totale du modèle
agricole français vous avez EUR
d'ailleurs oui mais justement vous avez
été députés européen d'où ma question
est-ce que c'est possible dans
l'organisation européenne actuel mais
bien sûr il suffit de moi la première
patte que j'ai négocié on a eu le
premier verdissement c'était quoi la
négociation quand j'ai quand je suis
arrivé COB c'est là que le poids de la
France quand même dans l'Europe agricole
ça compte moi j'ai ayant été
vice-président de la commission agricole
du Parlement je savais exactement ce que
je voulais faire versd dire alors que on
était en train de perdre cet objectif là
donc on peut le faire et au contraire ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est que la
nouvelle pâack qui en a discuté vous
avez entendu parler de la nouvelle pack
personne n'en a discuté il y a ce qu'on
appelle une renationalisation de la pack
c'estàd qu'on a renvoyé on a pris tout
ce qu'on avait négocié en
2013 ça c'est un socle le verdissement
que j'avais négocié c'est le socle et
après on a renvoyé à ce qu'on a appelé
une renationalisation avec je sais plus
comment s'appelle les les plans
stratégiques pour l'environnement donc
chaque État fait un plan stratégique
donc on renvoie aux États d'où le débat
agricole et des agriculteurs qui là pour
le coup est juste c'est la transposition
c'est qu'on a le sentiment que le socle
de base il est pour tout le monde et
puis après chaque État on rajoute alors
qu'il faudrait au contraire avoir un
socle plus exigeant mais pour tout le
monde le même c'est ça la question qui
est posée et bien dans cette réforme qui
a été négociée je suis désolé de le dire
au lieu de négocier pour tout le monde à
l'échelle européenne on a renvoyé chacun
à sa à sa responsabilité nationale ben
voilà il arrive ce qu'il arrive une
dernière question là-dessus avec la
guerre en Ukraine et pour soutenir les
Ukrainiens il y a eu beaucoup
d'importations de produit ukrainien
notamment de volail notamment poulet
est-ce qu'il faut réduire ces
importations pour aider les agriculteurs
français est-ce qu' aujourd'hui elle
mise à l'agriculture française alors je
pense que ça nuit bien sûr les
importations de Poul raen alors on va
devenir l'Ukraine va devenir le respons
responsable de la totalité des questions
des importations j'entends maintenant
aussi jeananch qui faut arrêter le libre
échange je vis juste donner un exemple
pour qu'on comprenne bien si je prends
la viticulture par exemple on exporte 50
% de plus que ce qu'on importe en 20 et
sur ces 50 % enfin sur les les
importations de vin 85 viennent de
l'Europe le jour où vous supprimez le
libre échange et donc vous exportez plus
et ça vaut pour toutes les productions
notre
auto comment dirais-je autoconsommation
autonomie ou souveraineté comme ça a été
appelé elle est liée à la part de ce que
l'on produit de ce que l'on consomme et
de ce qu'on exporte et de ce qu'on
importe quand vous retirer les
exportations on a des autonomies qui
sont autour de 80 à 100 % voire un peu
plus pour certain mais si je prends
l'exemple du 20 la moitié de ce que je
de ce que j'exporte c'est va revenir sur
le marché français à partir du moment où
vous faites ça parce que si vous
empêchez les importations vous allez
avoir du mal à réaliser des exp
exportation et bien ça veut dire qu'il y
a 50 % de ce qui est produit qui revient
sur le marché pr sur l'Ukraine là il y a
eu quelque chose qui a été fait dans la
précipitation contenue de la guerre il
faut mieux réguler on peut aider
l'Ukraine mais on n'est pas obligé de
déstabiliser la totalité des marchés
agricoles européens je le pense je le
crois question politique Fabrice
vous par vous l'évoquez tout à l'heure
ce rapport politique aussi à la FNSEA
est-ce que la droitisation l'extrême
droitisation du monde agricole vous
inquiète j'avais constaté quand j'allais
au salon de l' à Cournon hein je voyais
bien comment Marine Le Pen à l'époque
était accueilli et comment moi j'étis
accueilli alors même si dans le fond sur
les aides qu'on a mis en place sur
l'ensemble de l'élevage on avait fait
des progrès et que les responsables
agricoles quand on a discutait quand
considérrait quand même que ces
transferts de près d'un milliard d'euros
hein au niveau de cette pack verdit de
de verdissement avait été utile oui ça
m'inquiète mais ça m'inquiète de manière
plus générale et plus de manière plus
globale c'est pas simplement le monde
agricole et le monde agricole n'est pas
plus touché que le le reste de la
société aujourd'hui avec des solutions
qui sont totalement alors non seulement
contradictoire avec le JETI si on veut
défendre les agriculteurs si j'entends
bien ce que dit le rassemblement
national il faut sortir de la PAC ou
sortir de l'Europe c'est qu'on verse
plus rien sur le budget européen et donc
on va reverser ce qu'on versa à l'Europe
sur les questions agricooles faudra
trouver 9 milliards et demi un peu plus
de 10 d'ailleurs si je prends toutes les
aides hein il est complément 1er 2uxème
pilier plus ce qu'on appelle les il
disent qu'on verse beaucoup plus à
l'Europe que
je confirme on est contributeur net
c'est-à-dire qu'on verse plus qu'on
reçoit mais qui est le dans l'ordre les
bénéficiaires des des exportations
ensuite sur le marché européen en 1
c'est l'Allemagne en 2 c'est la France
c'estàdire que on a les fait simples je
contribue je donne du pouvoir d'achat si
j'exporte j'en bénéficie un mot sur la
gauche d'abord un petit mot pour les
européennes vous soutenez Raphaël glxman
je soutiens Raphaël gluxman parce que
c'est la liste qui semble-t-il va être
celle du Parti socialiste je dis
simplement à raphaë kluxman que vouloir
faire campagne tout seul sur on va créer
une surprise tout seul je crois que
c'est une erreur on créera une surprise
en terme de résultat si on est capable
de rassembler de créer une damque avec
qui bah de Bernard casenuve jusqu'à la
totalité des socialistes qui ont souvent
été montrés du doigt parce que ils
avaient été critiques par rapport à la
nupes c'est ça l'enjeu c'est de
réaffirmer une ligne politique
socialiste du socialisme français
jorécien social-démocrate c'est ça qu'il
faut faire d'abord là j'ai l'impression
que tout ça on passe plus de temps à
négocier une liste qu'à parler politique
pour la liste Nicolas mailleurossignol
qui est sur sur votre ligne il appelle
au rassemblement de François Ruffin
Bernard cas vousêt d'accord fr j'ai vu
le le le texte et le débat entre Raphael
kluxwan et François Ruffin qu'est-ce
qu'il dit François Ruffin il dit qu'on
est dans la lutte des classes d'ailleurs
il a considéré que clluxwan faisait
partie d'une classe qui était pas la
sienne moi je considère que je suis dans
la Sarte depuis que je suis né je suis
d'origine bretonne j'ai été dans un
canton le canton de Loué où par
exemplement achète la totalité de ses
poulets de sa volaille sur loué je sais
ce que c'est mais je répète on n plus
dans la lutte des classes on va rembl
jus le vrai problème de mais oui mais
moi je suis pour le rassemblement sur
quelle ligne pas jusqu'à lui du coup
mais pas jusqu'à lui parce que il n'est
pas sur la ligne que je porte il est
encore dans la lutte des classes je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure si je porte une
anal de la société avec un projet
politique mais que au nom de l'Alliance
je dis B en fait ce que je pense c'est
pas tout à fait la vérité donc pour
l'Alliance je me je choisis une autre
ligne non le vrai problème de tous ces
gens là aujourd'hui je voudrais leur
poser la question mais vous êtes où
exactement est-ce que vous le savez
vous-même c'est ça le problème que j'ai
même avec Nicolas Mayer signal le côté
je rassemble jusqu'à Rufin parce que on
cherche à diviser la l PES enfin il faut
d'abord être cohérent faut savoir où on
va ça vaut pour l'agriculture le cap le
côté en même temps répliqué pour la
gauche pour la droite pour l'extrême
droite ça va finir par brouiller tout
donc le rassemblement c'est quoi c'est
l'ensemble des lignes du PS plus le
Parti radical de gauche ça va
coup je reviens oui le Parti radical de
gauche sur quelle ligne
eston sommes-nous qui la
partage c'est pas simplement je me
rassemble pour me rassembler c'est
devenu un leg motif qui est assez
bizarre je me rassemble pour me rassem
stratégiquement et d'ailleurs c'est le
PC qui l'avait
dit l'Union c'est un combat c'est un
combat pourquoi parce qu'il y avait des
lignes différenceente il y avait une
concurrence là aujourd'hui il y a plus
de concurrence il y a simplement l'idée
on se rassemble pour se rassembler B non
on se rassemble pas pour se rassembler
on se rassemble pour faire quelque chose
mais pour faire quelque chose faut avoir
une ligne politique un dernier mot
est-ce que la droitisation du
gouvernement est une auine pour vous et
est-ce que pour cela vous demandez à
Olivier fort de rompre clairement avec
la France je pense que la droitisation
de d'Emmanuel Macron et du macronisme
c'est pas une auben mais il y a un une
fenêtre stratégique très importante
quell conditions et quelles conditions
pour pouvoir les conditionition c'est
d'avoir et d'affirmer une lecture de la
société et d'avoir une ligne aujourd'hui
à force de suivre qu'on a pas le PS
aujourd'hui toujours aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs sur la question aricole qu
est la ligne je sais pas j'ai pas vu une
expression je je là aujourd'hui je c'est
ma première expression télévision parce
que j'avais le mon sonore un très beau
dianal du son avant je je je vais
essayer de de parler sur le fond et pas
simplement faire de répéter ce que tout
le monde dit mais le PS il est où c'est
bien ça le sujet Comment vous
l'expliquez comment je l'explique mais
je l'explique parce que c'est après le
le le quinqu de François Hollande et le
fait que François Hollande n'est pas pu
se représenter il n pas souhaité n pas
plus il y a eu une volonté elle était
légitime j'ai perdu conré d'bervillier
sur la page tourné de Hollande ça je
l'ai compris mais une fois qu'on a dit
qu'on tourne une page faut en écrire une
autre c'est là que elle est toujours pas
écrite ben non loin s'en fut merci
Stéphane lefolle merci BECI à vous en
tout cas d'avé dans votre magnifique
studio que je découvre ce matin c'est un
plaisir bonne année à tout le monde et
bonne année à vous merci Fabrice à la
semaine prochaine on passe au club des
territoires